buongiorno a tutti grazie di essere qui
insomma abbastanza impressionante vedere
quest aula gremita scuserete il mio
italiano da francese
farò quello che potrò in questa
bellissima lingua allora io vengo da
dalle campagne dalle campagne di quello
che ovviamente una volta era anche la
gaia romana quindi possiamo parlare di
mediterraneo di colonialismo anche
antico sono tematiche e un po politiche
che non vorrei qui affrontare e vengo da
un vengo da un paese piccolissimo che si
chiama figeac 9 mila abitanti sono
originario da lì e che è situato nella
provincia che si chiama lotto il lotto è
un fiume
ovviamente noi nel lotto cresciuti li
dall'altro lato del fiume si vedeva un
altra provincia che si chiama la vero e
da bambino e da adolescente se ti piace
piva con grande violenza direi il senso
della frontiera perché perché quelli
della vero erano quelli di là e noi
eravamo di qua e spesso finiva cazzo
tate in qualche ballo di paese o vecchie
balle re di una volta quindi in questi
territori remoti di campania beh c'è un
senso dell'identità e delle frontiere
molto direi ruspante a volte molto
solido e questo lo ritroviamo anche in
italiano non sto qui a farvi la la
storia delle contrade senesi o altre
cose simpatiche del genere ecco quindi
le nostre storie le nostre i nostri e
oltre vecchissime nazioni vecchissimi
territori sono pieni di questi esempi
insomma di divisione ma queste divisioni
poi si supera lo è io vi do qualche
esempio tratto dalla mia storia la
storia più locale del mio paesino non so
se qualcuno conosce questo ritratto e
giacchino murat giachino mira lo vedete
qua nel suo ritratto di re di napoli
beh giachino mera era il figlio di un
proprietario di trattorie a 20
chilometri di casa mia in mezzo proprio
al nulla li sono territori dove ci sono
più piccole più capre che essere umani
insomma proprio zona zone rurali e lo so
questo questo personaggio poi fece il
seminario arrivo la rivoluzione fans
carriera di militare seguaci di
napoleone maresciallo di francia sposa
la sorella di napoleone diventa poi re
di napoli
a un certo punto destino assurdo destino
che finirà più top in modo abbastanza
tragico a pizzo calabro
insomma questa è un'altra cosa questo un
altro
un altro esempio questa cosa molto
strana è un'opera d'arte da da questo
bellissimo artista joseph cous con sun
scultore americano e è una piazza del
mio paese di nascita sia qui si chiama
applausi cricchio questa piazza
ovviamente una riproduzione della stella
di rosa e rosetta stone che sta al
british museum a londra che il
cosiddetto cappuccio diplo l'emea dove
c'è una scrittura di egiziani antico
verso l'altro poi copto in mezzo e greco
in fondo è stato con questa con questo
reperto che jean françois champollion è
nato a fila a il primo scoperto il
significato è tradotto la scrittura
egizia e quindi anche lì un personaggio
nato proprio lì dove hanno poi oggi
fatto questa piazza ovviamente sono cose
moderne è andato al di là delle
frontiere se posso dire questo sono
frontiere culturali incredibili terzo
esempio che a me piace moltissimo e che
ormai oggi non è più conosciuto charles
boyer ovvero sull dwyer questo signore
che vedete in questa foto sta negli anni
30 è stata proprio questa foto ed era un
immensa star di hollywood e ogni 30 cara
40 era il latin lover di hollywood era
il figlio di un mercato di attrezzi
agricoli sempre del mio paese che poi
dopo la prima guerra mondiale insomma è
partito per hollywood e ha conosciuto
una carriera favolosa
tutto questo per dirvi che ecco c'è
anche nelle zone questi territori più
arretrati abbiamo questi esempi di
superamento incredibili delle frontiere
però io adesso vi parlo un po di di
alcune esperienze mi è che io ho
superato le frontiere le frontiere ho
iniziato a superarle da studente quando
insomma ormai un anziano signore si
faceva il giro dell'europa con l'inter e
l'inter è che voi non conoscete perché
avete low cost però all'epoca uno
comprava un biglietto e con quel
biglietto di treno girava tipo tutto
l'estate l'europa uno andava che ne so
nei paesi scandinavi per alcuni motivi
un andava in spagna o in italia per
altri motivi
ovviamente con lo zaino le spalle in
carrozze a volte un po puzzolente
insomma era tutto una cosa piuttosto
simpatica però li ha in quell'epoca
beh incredibile uno si doveva fermare ce
ne sento parlare il treno e poi saranno
le frontiere frontiere dove la prima
cosa è che si cambiavano le valute la
moneta una cosa proprio pesante
arrivando in italia ovviamente c'era la
lira e quindi uno girava comunque non so
se il cambio tutte queste cose che oggi
non ci sono più che voi in europa non
conoscete più però insomma era veramente
una cosa disdicevole e poi ovviamente le
dogane questi beni doganieri all'epoca
uno doveva fare controlli passaporto
tutto questo è sparito e tornerò su
questo dell'unione europea ed è una cosa
abbastanza favolosa ma la frontiera
comunque che io ho sperimentato in
questi primi viaggi da adolescente da
studente è un posto magico la frontiera
perché magico la frontiera a volte un
fiume la frontiera una montagna la
frontiera volta non è nulla però è un
posto dove la geografia non cambia la
genetica degli esseri umani
nemmeno però si cambia lingua si cambia
abitudine c'è chi guida a sinistra guida
dell e per quali motivi o dei motivi
antichi dei motivi storici ma volendo
non c'è non c'è buon motivo è io mi
ricordo poi uno all'epoca fra queste
cose magiche avvicinandosi all italia
c'era il caffè c'è uno in francia prima
della frontiera beveva ed è tutt ora
beve un caffè piuttosto cattivo poi
magia delle magie hop si passa da
frontiere il caffè buono non so io
vorrei un caffé buono dovunque poi non
so non è che qui di quel mondo quel
mondo le frontiere e va cambiato ecco e
quindi attende il nome di questo qua
buono l'unione europea anche per altri
motivi ha cambiato parecchie cose la
frontiera teoricamente io sono anche un
po politologo la frontiera è un posto
che è stato spesso il frutto da lotte
note tribali o ricordo quel bellissimo
libro anche piuttosto umoristico di roy
lewis dove si vedono delle tribù
preistoriche e voi alle 21 va a rapire
le donne dell'altra tribù e così estende
il suo potere
beh questo insomma questa cosa spiega
molto molto a dinamica che in modo un po
più serio poi è stata illustrata dal
nord per elias che in questi libri di
filosofia ha fatto vedere questa
dinamica delle frontiere in occidente
quindi i clan la tribù si e spende con
delle conquiste le conquiste possono
essere violente ma possono anche essere
delle conquiste amorose ad esempio il
matrimonio è stato sempre un modo di
allargarle sorgerà un principe una
principessa a mettono un regno più
grandi insieme e via
l'europa però ha fatto qualcosa di
diverso squadra in più non ha più fatto
nei conquiste nel frontiere insomma ha
avuto quest'allargamento incredibile
negli ultimi ultimi decenni
a tal punto poi di arrivare a delle
questione abbastanza paradossale non
soltanto l'integrazione europea fatto
sparire le frontiere e quello lì
possiamo richiamare ai nostri padri
fondatori poi fonatorio europea della
commissione della comunità all'epoca
però ci sono stati poi degli eventi
storici soprattutto il muro di berlino
crollo del muro di berlino ha fatto
esplodere completamente la frontiera fra
due blocchi cosa che era sentita in modo
molto molto pesante alla fine degli anni
80 questi tedeschi dell'est che sono
passati tramite l'ungheria per poi
entrare nostra e arrivare nella germania
federale dell'epoca della ovest rendendo
completamente inutile con la vecchia
frontiera del muro ha creato un senso
ulteriore ed inutilità della frontiera e
da questo momento abbiamo avuto un nuovo
concetto cioè dell'interno dell'unione
europea abbiamo pensato che le frontiere
non dovevano più
se delle barriere bensì dei luoghi di
cooperazione e quindi eccoci qua con
questa cosiddetta politica
transfrontalieri interregionale e vedete
su questa mappa le frontiere poi sono
luoghi oggi di cooperazione di sviluppo
delle specifiche politiche pubbliche che
fanno sì che si possono sviluppare
progetti culturali progetti sociali
progetti turistici e via dicendo
e quindi nell'europa c'è un enorme
evoluzione della frontiera un enorme
paradosso cioè il paradosso di della
divisione che poi che esiste tuttora
perché il caffè è sempre cattivo da una
parte sempre buona dall'altro non si può
cancellare una storia del caffè così
però allo stesso tempo non soltanto
l'europa sia allargata e quindi le
frontiere interne sono diventate sempre
più labili ma questo insomma anche
nell'unità d'italia è successo così
nell'ottocento ma poi queste frontiere
oggi diventano paradossalmente dei
luoghi di cooperazione quindi con un
senso completo è completamente capovolto
della frontiera questo ci porta a una
riflessione doveva più l'ampia più larga
l'europa è un blob sapete un blog
insomma questa specie di forma diffusa
chi invade che che però che come lo dice
questa pubblicità di questo film di
fantascienza piuttosto divertente e
inarrestabile
non potete fermarlo oggi molti dicono al
oropa in crisi ed è vero c'è una crisi
economica magari ne stiamo anche uscendo
speriamo però questo blog da un senso di
d d d d cosa un po pervasiva ma è anche
molto positivo nel senso che queste
barriere
abbiamo avuto un forte senso in europa
ultimamente di barriere che cadevano e
io penso fondamentalmente che sia
all'interno ma che anche all'esterno
questo è un movimento che proseguirà ed
è lì che poi arriva anche il
mediterraneo c'è lo stesso così con un
certo non dico umorismo ma insomma la
certa leggerezza
vi ho fatto vedere alcune storie
personali la mia ma anche quella di
personaggi che poi superano queste
frontiere culture
e tra l'altro con un rapporto
particolare quello con l'italia perché
un re di napoli che viene dalle mie
province infine il fondo della francia
rurale insomma non è da poco
però abbiamo di fronte a noi un
mediterraneo che dobbiamo considerare
anche con un momento come un terreno
aperto certo pieno di contraddizioni ma
come abbiamo aperto le nostre frontiere
al nord ea nord est
io penso che dobbiamo intellettualmente
ma non soltanto anche aprire le
frontiere a sud e vi ringrazio